now the polls have finally closed in
India's marathon election which began
back in early April exit polls are
predicting that Prime Minister Narendra
Modi's Hindu nationalist party and its
allies will win the right to govern for
another five years or the grueling 39
day election provided for 900 million
voters to be polled over seven rounds of
voting a million polling stations were
set up across India for the elections
and sixteen million government employees
and security force members tasked with
overseeing the process well over 2,000
political parties contested these
elections and this democracy has a hefty
price tag the elections expected to
exceed the 3.8 billion pounds spent in
2014 or from Delhi skies never Lazarus
reports it is the largest Democratic
exercise in the world India's last phase
of elections concluded today after a
period of 39 days with 900 million
eligible voters the fate of 8,000
candidates hangs in the balance almost
16 million personnel including police
military and state and federal employees
reach voters across the country a
million polling booths were set up in
villages from the Himalayas in the north
to the southern tip of the subcontinent
Prime Minister Narendra Modi is running
for a second term
he swept to power in 2014 with an
overwhelming majority
it was for the first time in 30 years a
single party won a majority he remains
the face and main vote getter of the
Bharatiya janta party but his image has
taken a beating over the year due to
economic problems and rural distress
under his rule strident Hindu
nationalism has become mainstream
threatening the social fabric of the
country attacks on minority communities
increased including incidents of
lynching of Muslim men accused of cow
slaughter his challenge comes from the
Congress party under the leadership of
Rahul Gandhi and other regional leaders
the opposition have campaigned on the
broken promises of Modi on unemployment
and economic growth with 60% of India's
population involved in agriculture the
farming crisis does not bode well for
the prime minister but his decisive
action against terrorism and archrival
Pakistan earlier this year has given him
a boost as a strong leader national
security became the main focus and
further propelled Modi's popularity his
fate and that of 1.3 billion Indians
will be known next Thursday when results
are due whatever the outcome the
democratic process of getting hundreds
of millions to cast their vote for their
future is a clear winner never Lazarus
Sky News Delhi